the summer heat has arrived and that
heat can take a toll on our skin
here to help us with skin care tips is
alexander sherman
the founder and lead esthetician of the
lab first off congratulations on the
opening of the lab
and what are a few of the unique
services that you guys are offering
thank you so much for having me uh we're
offering some oxygenating treatments
by a line called biological cherish
which is a french-based
product line and it's brand new to vegas
and i'm so excited it's going to help
brighten the skin oxygenate the cells
and really prepare you for the summer
is is oxygen key when it comes to a
proper skin routine is the first i'm
hearing using the oxygen on your face
is this a key thing to be using
absolutely it can really help with cell
turnover which is
what we're looking for when dealing with
sun damage and the summer heat in vegas
so i was reading that you want to
encourage men to come in do you have any
special treatments
for men yeah we have a whole range of
treatments for men
one particularly being our final table
facial
and that helps men especially before a
big
meeting or if they're just a poker
player getting into their final table
it'll really help brighten their skin
and
help her do some wrinkles and with
ingrown hairs as well
so this is not when you get this done
you're not going to walk into a big
meeting with a bright red face
you're gonna look glowing and fresh
afterwards
absolutely not yeah you'll be glowing
ready to go and um really just bright
before you're before any big day all
right you can put me down for one of
those
uh let's talk about skin hydration tips
for summer what are some things that
everyone watching right now can do to
help their skin
well you know it's a fun time in vegas
so i would say just please remember to
hydrate
and using a hydrating sunscreen is a
great way
to maintain hydration levels in the skin
while also protecting from harmful uv
rays and gun damage
so uh before i let you go what is what
is your favorite service
that that your that you guys offer
oh my favorite treatment is called the
vipo2 treatment it's part of a
biological
custom treatment all of our facials are
100
customized to each person's skin and
it's never going to be the same
because everyone's skin changes on a
day-to-day basis
so it's really my favorite treatment is
aside from vipo2 just anything
that that client needs at the moment
that they come to see me
alexandra when it comes to using spf
what's the base level we should be using
for everyone watching right now and they
want to put some spf before they go out
in the morning
what's the base level that we should
start with
i would recommend starting with spf 30.
the most important thing is to really
just reapply
if you find yourself outside constantly
throughout the day
it will wear off over time so just
constantly reapplying your sunscreen is
my biggest
and most important advice i love it so
real quick what's the website before we
wrap things up
at www.thelabssp.com
awesome and thank you alexandra again
congratulations on opening up the new
shop it's fantastic
in las vegas now will be